madeleine sébastien mort soir bonsoir on
va initier ce panel politique tristement
par une scènes disgracieuses qui a
marqué l'actualité cette semaine je vous
mets ça rapidement contexte c'était pire
bourreau en ontario dans le contexte la
campagne électorale provinciale dans
cette province et puis là aux abords
d'un local électoral du npd voici ce qui
s'est produit
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas montré le montrer l'entièreté
de la scène il ya certaines paroles
qu'on ne préfère ne pas retransmettre
encore une fois ici sur nos jours mais
bref monsieur jobs meeting madeleine a
été harcelé avec des paroles blessantes
et italie bref vraiment vraiment trop
loin c'est pas la première fois qu'il
subit comme ça des des gens qui le
suivent une fois il y avait été victime
d'une soi-disant arrestation citoyenne
là quelqu'un qui essayait de l'arrêter
mais il a dit que cette fois-ci bon le
taux d'agressivité était plus élevé que
ce à quoi ils avaient été confrontés
dans le passé il dit moi j'ai fait des
arts martiaux je sais comment me
défendre mais ça devrait pas être un
prérequis pour faire de la politique
fédérale ou faire de la politique tout
court est ce qu'on constate
malheureusement c'est qu'il y à une
hausse des incidents comme sont
menaçants c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
le service canadien de renseignement de
sécurité qui a publié très récemment un
rapport qui le disaient que ces deux
dernières années en temps de pandémie il
y a eu plus de manifestations violentes
à l'endroit de politiciens donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire une fois
qu'on a dit ça il ya toutes sortes de
choses qu'on peut faire plusieurs angles
avec lesquels on peut aborder cette
question lors que ce soit l'angle de la
sécurité les chefs de partis
d'opposition ont pas de gardes du corps
hors campagne électorale je pense qu'à
québec on est dans un monde complètement
différent
il ya toute la question du discours
aussi quel ton les politiciens doivent
adopter et finalement le gouvernement
fédéral veut se pencher sur la question
de la lutte de la haine en ligne parce
que ce qui se retrouve dans les médias
sociaux se retrouvent trop souvent
maintenant hors des médias sociaux si ce
qu'on craint au gouvernement fédéral
donc il y a une promesse de déposer un
projet de loi pour essayer de combattre
la haine en ligne il y avait aussi une
promesse de le faire dans les 100
premiers jours et cette promesse n'a
pour le moment ne pas été respectées
jack meeting a été très courageux je
trouve leur se tester dans là c'est à
dire qu'il est allé au devant des
manifestants ils disent à 100 les
affronter il les offre
il est passé à travers les manifestants
mais ça aurait pu être très dangereux
que si quelqu'un avait décidé de lui
sauter dessus s'arrêter tout à fait
possible et moi je suis surpris voire
même sidéré d'apprendre en fait je le
savais mais comment de lundi les chefs
des partis d'opposition d'avoir non pas
de gardes du corps et c'est un monde
complètement différent québec tu sais
comment c'est vrai québec il ya des
constables ce qu'on appelle des
constables spéciaux donc l'équivalent de
des agents des constables qui sont dans
les palais de justice par exemple des
gens armés mais habillés en civil qui
sont les gardes du corps des ministres
et des chefs des partis d'opposition
donc il son garde du corps ils sont
chauffeurs en même temps ils sont armés
c'est dire qu'ils ont un revolver à la
nature ils sont capables donc de
défendre le ministre ou le chef du parti
qui serait agressé attaqué je comprends
pas qu'ils arrêtent à voir on a soit pas
pendre c'est c'est peut-être bien qu'on
en soit pas rendue là parce que sa note
qu'ils payeront une proximité entre le
politicien et la population mais quand
on assiste à des scènes comme celle là
c'est plus dangereux qu'autre chose oui
la réflexion monsieur singh a été entre
autres la suivante mais voilà le genre
de scène qui va décourager certaines
personnes de se lancer en politique
n'est ce pas madeleine mais justement
quand je vous disais que ça devrait pas
être un prérequis d'être capable de
défendre physiquement c'est un peu ce
qu'il voulait dire et souvenez-vous en
campagne électorale lorsqu'on voyait ces
gens suivre justin trudeau dans les
différents événements de campagne reçu
du gravier par exemple de la part de
manifestants qui lui avait lancé des
petites roches on est dans un autre
dans une autre dynamique là on n'est pas
dans un débat d'idées on est dans une
polarisation qui peut devenir dangereuse
et je pense que c'est important de
s'attarder à cette question là
évidemment si on entoure les politiciens
de sécurité c'est une chose mais il
faudrait peut-être ainsi pensé en amont
comment essayer de bien faire baisser la
pression et peut-être éduquer la
population aussi à certaines civilité là
à l'endroit des politiciens parce que
évidemment ce sont des êtres humains
comme nous tous et ils méritent pas ça
du tout en sentant les opinions peuvent
être exprimés on est dans une société
libre où il ya la liberté d'expression
mais c'est la façon aussi d'exprimer ses
opinions la façon d'exprimer l'opinion
envers john manning était
inacceptable juste en quelques mots
madeleine pour qu'on comprenne bien ce
qu'on en sait un peu plus sur ce que en
fait ce que reproche ces gens à john
meeting qu'elle était l'essence de leur
message au delà des décos ligue des
quolibets désobligeants qui ont été
prononcées non c'était très difficile
d'avoir véritablement le fond de leur
pensée quand il traitait john meeting de
traître qu'est ce que ça veut dire ou
juste traîtres au sujet de quoi on
semblait pas tout à fait incarner dans
une réalité ou un discours cohérent je
vous dirai pas ce genre d injures y
avait il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas
de différents messages prochaine non
j'ai entendu un des manifestants
criaient faire référence aux convois de
camionneurs que jack meeting s'ils
étaient fortement opposés était en
faveur de l'adoption de l'invocation de
la loi sur les mesures d'urgence j'ai vu
un manifestant aussi tenir brandir la
charte canadienne des libertés collé sur
un poster donc vous voyez parfois
lorsqu'on évoque la charte c'est pour
des questions de liberté d'expression
souvent s'est rattaché mais en même
temps là je suis pas allé questionner
mais la police va faire enquête la
police de peterborough puis la grc va se
pencher là dessus voilà on en saura
peut-être plus un peu plus tard qui sait
maintenant ce sas a eu pas mal d'échos
cours des dernières heures il ya eu un
développement quoi au cours de la
dernière heure et demie sébastien le
débat des chefs en anglais lors de la
prochaine campagne électorale il est
annulé raison très simple messieurs
legault et st pierre plamondon avait
déjà dit qu'il ne voulait pas y
participer oui et pas le saint-père
vraiment nous on a fait une question de
principe qui pipe qui peut se défendre
qui est sujet à débat de dire que le
français la langue officielle et commune
au québec et que de faire un débat en
anglais c'est pas nécessaire au québec
dans une campagne acteurs jean françois
lisée en passant en 2018 avait fait le
pari inverse il avait fait le pari que
je serais capable de convaincre les
anglophones ne reparte qu'un
gouvernement du parti québécois pour
être un bon gouvernement qui mettrait
les aînés les patients les enfants
en priorité que les politiques vertes
également
françois legault par contre ça c'est le
tweet de paul st pierre plamondon qui
parle d'un homme française mail excuses
de françois legault c'est de dire j'ai
pas le temps ça prend trop de temps
préparer un débat en anglais c'est
excuses là elle est discutable que vous
savez quand quelqu'un vous appelle et
vous demande un rendez-vous puisque
votre excuse c'est de dire que vous avez
pas de temps c'est parce que vous vous
souciez pas de vouloir communiquer avec
cette personne si vous trouvez ça
important vous trouvé le temps de faire
quelque chose et donc françois legault
dit j'ai pas le temps pourquoi il dit
j'ai pas le top c'est parce qu'il trouve
pas ça important de discuter avec eux
mais avec la communauté anglophone
pourquoi il trouve pas c'est important
parce qu'il en a pas besoin
politiquement électeurs allemands leur
lancée voilà politiquement et
électoralement il n'a pas besoin du vote
anglophone mais c'est le premier
ministre de tous les québécois franco
anglophone et comme premier ministre on
pourrait s'attendre à ce qu'ils
communiquent avec tous les québécois
quitte à les convaincre que sa loi 96 le
projet devant 96 qui va être adopté
bientôt est la bonne chose à faire mais
on s'attendrait en tant que premier
ministre qu'il participe à ce débat et
il avait eu le temps lors de la dernière
campagne lecteurs parce qu'ils avaient
quelque chose à gagner il essayait de
gruger d appoint au parti libéral du
québec
cette fois ci comme dit sébastien il n'y
a pas besoin de cet électorat là pour
mais selon les sondages actuels
reprendre le pouvoir en même temps
peut-être qu'il n'aurait pas beaucoup de
ses appuis en raison de différentes
initiatives du de la caq au cours des
dernières semaines des derniers mois par
exemple le projet de loi 96 mais comme
le dit sébastien quand on laisse
entendre qu'on n'est pas assez important
pour passer quelques heures de
préparation de débat ça vaut pas
nécessairement améliorer le climat
social ensuite et ça va pas
nécessairement calmer des esprits qui
ont été chauffées notamment par le
projet de loi 4 ce sera perçu ce sera
peut-être perçu par la communauté
anglophone comme et il ya deux types de
québécois et les francophones à qui on
serrait ce qui est acquis on apporte du
top il ya les anglophones
qui sont pourtant des québécois il n'y a
pas deux catégories de québécois ou deux
catégories de citoyens alors c'est ce
sera peut-être interprété comme un
message divisif de la part de françois
way est une communauté anglo québécoise
ou anglo montréalaise qui se sent déjà
10 plusieurs orphelinats politiquement
parlant il ya deux nouveaux partis qui
ont été lancés s'est pas encore
formalisé mais quand même
ça ça va brasser un peu les cartes dans
l'esprit des de cette communauté ça
c'est sûr et certain il nous laisse il
nous reste quelques instants pour parler
de ce qui est à surveiller justement
quelque chose en lien avec la question
de la langue sébastien surveiller
bientôt la wii dès demain en fait il ya
une manifestation contre le projet de
loi 96 qui a de particulier c'est que
les libéraux du québec vont être là en
force c'est à dire qu'on s'est donné le
mot parti libéral du québec pour
participer à cette manifestation heures
si vous voulez les reconnaître dans la
manifestation on leur a demandé de
porter du rouge donc la position est
ferme on est contre le projet de loi 96
et je pense c'est daniel leblanc notre
collègue de travail qui nous apprenait
aussi que ray des députés fédéraux
libéraux qui y participeraient une
poignée mais dont on devrait envoyer un
message qu'on appuie les gens qui sont
contre le projet de loi 96 c'est pas une
initiative gouvernementale de la part du
parti libéral fédéral mais il ya des
députés de la communauté anglophone
notamment du québec là qui vont être
présents pour appuyer finalement la
communauté anglophone et ce que
j'entends c'est qu'ils se sont pas
nécessairement ils sont pas
nécessairement que le parti libéral est
en train de faire pleinement son travail
en tout cas ils reçoivent semble-t-il
beaucoup d'appels dans leur très bon
pour essayer de défendre leur cause et
c'est entre autres pour ça qu'ils
iraient là selon ce que j'ai entendu à
votre très bien et madeleine rapidement
que vous seriez quelque chose en
particulier la semaine prochaine la
visite du prince charles
moi je vais animer une émission spéciale
la tumeur c'est vrai eh ben on va
regarder ça oui à part
certainement déroulera le tapis rouge
madeleine et sébastien allais au revoir
portez vous bien il ya bientôt j'espère
qu'en week end salut pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i cirdi